[Applaudissements]
maitre gims ou stromae
oui alors maître gims ou stromae on
rappelle gims a coécrit votre dernier
album stromae a participé aussi j'ai
droit devant est dit que si je vais pas
tout seul quoi non il faut choisir n'en
faut choisir faut choisir
mais c'est jura c'est mon ami et allaoui
métro tram il stromae et en plus ce
monstre au maillot on est sûr qu'il nous
regarde
maitre gims je sais qu'il nous regarde
souvent sinon c'est notre pote aussi on
le crif
mais c'est quoi natation cela monsieur
ne sortira pas dit si je vais choisir
parce que c'est mon ami je vais dire
juste parce que c'est mon ami vraiment
c'est mon ami dans l'intimité voilà
est-ce qu'on aurait aussi aimé on se
connaît depuis moins longtemps et c'est
vrai que game c'est vrai je prends tu
prends gims way surprise pour moi ce à
quoi on peut la balance note dans ce cas
d'asthme on voit que sur une vidéo total
et viennent nous offre une mouette a
fait un petit truc spécial
c'est vrai pour nous pour travailler et
il fait jamais de vidéos dans mes shows
c'est non mais bon la vie qui m'a dit je
veux lui faire une vidéo j'aime beaucoup
de séries tu veux lui faire un petit
saint amour on récupère touché
franchement je travaille donc lannion
mais une vidéo loi normale alors enrichi
mais trop basse et c'est l'offre et tout
ça c'est pas une vanne voir si je les
connais c'est ça fait deux ans qu'il n'a
pas parlé ce trauma il nous a fait
défaut menace est vraiment c'est pour
toi et pour tous le tout l'équipe ce
qu'il aime tout le monde et non non
c'est bon vous cadeau non j'ai pas un
gars qui était pas mais trop c'est trop
jul regarder une ampoule ou soprano vous
avez fait un duo avec les deux ça les
dérange avec jul et pas cette fois avec
soprano - aime tant ouais c'est ça je te
[ __ ] je te fous dans la merde non
après j'aurais été paré mois dans
l'année en bvb 2,1 alors
non je dirais plus gérer sopra parce
qu'on se connaît depuis longtemps et
pour le la carrière quoi d'accord voilà
tout avait elle a choisi sopra